so this dance spoke it's been 55 seconds
there's 55 seconds I've managed to judge
each him everyone kind of scary huh took
me 55 seconds to actually look at your
resume look you in the eye look at the
things you've done in the last five to
ten years and throw you to the trustee
you know in fact most HR people spends
30 seconds I'm looking at your resume
that first glance so today we want to
talk to you a little bit about how to go
through that first initial stop stone
and then how to look at three specific
problems that are right specifically the
GSB so that the first impression is what
matters
this is a resume you know you want to
crisp clear and it points in the right
directions the second thing is you've
got to start thinking as a recruiter you
that's a lot of text so what would they
spend their 30 seconds you want to give
the information so it's easy to identify
you're going to be looking for where you
went to school what's the name of the
last few firms some dates in some
locations if you make it easy for them
to look for that information you will
make it a lot easier to highlight what's
important to spend more time on other
areas the second thing is they're only
going to read the first the top of the
resume only the first few words of each
line you know it sounds ridiculous
because you have to write all the rest
of it it's important but that's really
where you should spend your time on an
attention the last thing is it's kind of
like when you're flipping through a
magazine you have a picture to picture
well they tend to go from number to
number so if you have numbers are
important and can highlight the specific
areas that's really what you like them
to be in summary you want it to be crisp
and organized and clean you want to
focus and point it in the right
direction to where you shouldn't start
spending time line you want to focus on
where they're gonna look at first and
lastly you want to make sure you put the
numbers so that they're guided two of
those directions so today I'm going to
talk about three specific people
Scott radiant out there to share with us
some of the complications of this 30
second or 60 second view of your resume
from their perspectives from Scott's
perspective as a banker that's changing
careers from rady's perspectives into
negative international applying in the
US and from pals perspective how it is
to apply it to work here at the Silicon
Valley all right I want to start by
asking how many people came to graduate
school to change careers that looks
about right so the CMC the Career
Management Center at the GSB said that
75% of GSB students are career changers
and many more of us will change careers
in the first few years after leaving the
GSB now I myself am a career changer
prior to coming in the GSB I was a
baseball player then I was an investment
banker that I was a solar energy guy all
of which leads to a very linear perfect
straight career path into education so
one of the reasons why I became
interested in the education is because
there's a high need for people with
finance and operations skills I have
those skills yet when I first started to
look at jobs and even offer to intern
for free I couldn't take anybody serious
I couldn't get anybody to take me
seriously so I want to share with you
guys two tips and pieces of advice that
I learned that are also but also
happened to be the two biggest mistakes
that career changers make on the resumes
at the GSB so you guys will be able to
use these going forward so a career
changer advice number one is to remove
non-essential industry-specific
technical language from your resume so
here's my resume here's a part of my
resume before I started at the GSB a now
amber McCoy you worked in education do
you have any idea what this means no
exactly so someone who worked in
investment banking might have a pretty
good idea of what all this is but me
trying to go in and speak to someone in
education they have no idea the type of
skill set that I can bring so what did I
do
well first I took away all the
transactions to be to be frank no one
really cares about those anyway outside
of banking second I realized that the
term quantitative valuation analysis was
too technical for people in education so
I switched it to say to measure the
value of companies which it was a lot
simpler and finally I took that second
bullet point and changed it to show that
basically I was able to build something
small into something big and in any
industry that's an important experience
to have so my second piece of advice is
to demonstrate interest in your new
field I worked at first all over Cade
before I came to the GSB and I'd also
done a bunch of community service but
when I went to go interview people in
education they say why you know given
your background why the hell do you want
to do this and what I realized is that I
had initially left out a couple
important things that would have
mitigated that question so the first
thing I did was I added a bullet point
that talked about my volunteer
experience at my last company now if you
were to look at the other three bullet
points I spent probably 95% of my time
on those and maybe 5% on that last one
every interview I've gone into for the
past two years that last bullet point is
what's been focused on I've also done
community service with a couple of
different organizations but I focus it
on my work with big brothers to show
that I've made a long-term commitment to
kids so by doing this and by making a
few simple language two weeks I was able
to convince people in education that I
cared and then I was right for a job
I also will begin with questions so how
many of you are international student
please raise your hand
so how many of you like to find is so
different of the resume here and in your
country on here you need to rewritten
your resume to apply up here please
raise your hand oh pretty much
and also I'm come to China I will work
here in sama I want to work here after
graduation so today I will talk about
the difference of the resume in China
here and also share some tips how to
prepare a resume to apply job here at an
international student about the resume
in China I try to do some research
online recently I think of one new
channel especially among the college
students they try to spend a lot of
money to design their resume to end more
design elements into the read name but
we all know that doesn't work is waste
of money they only make your resume
looks less professional and the second
things in China are people like to put a
lot of personal information on the
resume let the pictures genders
nationality and even some girls put
south side of them like these things get
especially jobs
we all know that in America when a
company saw all the information on your
resume they will throw it into trash
directory because they don't have anyone
based on some discrimination and the
don't get shoe the last thing is usually
we have cheap hedges which had put all
the information on them beside and
personal information like all the awards
in even run a high school and all these
things and those things is we sometimes
we eat check it generated the
information a little is the very
comprehensive topic anyone are
interested at that we can talk in the
Q&A section so how to adjust your resume
to a prior job here I have three tips
the first thing is you try to reduce the
catch of difference the most direct way
to do it she just asked others opinions
for example talk to some native speakers
let them to look through your resume to
figure out you deliver the information
you want and also can talk to some
people like from CMC Career Center to
get some very professional opinions and
the second thing is love helps you
prioritize your information especially
from others perspectives to think about
what companies really want to know from
you and just keep that information on
your resume and the first things we we
have the honor code here and now this is
a really serious issue here so always
tell your story and deliver all the
information in a very fire on honest
away
so in addition to the resume part you're
also being constantly judged and that is
by your online I mean online it is a new
medium in which employers can have a
better understanding of who you are what
you do where you come from what hobbies
you choose outside of the context of the
traditional resume and cover letter any
of you and did you know that 95% of all
companies use some form of social media
to recruit new talent well with that
with that in mind I'm confident that
you're competitive and be a people
probably think how will this make me get
ahead of the game
and so social networks have expanded
your contacts however the real challenge
now lies in your ability to understand
how to leverage these opportunities to
establish new connections and turn them
into real opportunities and so let me
start off with with a LinkedIn I'm
pretty sure that most of you all of you
have LinkedIn profiles however um I
would like to offer some tips on how to
maximize the exposure so there are about
a billion searches annually every
Arlington although while some are for
people and companies some are for
keywords and when you place these
keywords who matters a lot for example
the top four highest ranking go to name
title skill and missing headline which
headlines matter a lot for your LinkedIn
profile similar to a newspaper article
headlines need to grab the attention and
it needs to tell what differentiates you
what makes you special and what you want
to be known for and recommendations and
endorsements these are some of the new
features of LinkedIn they're not
necessarily related to the search aspect
however they definitely add credibility
to your profile so why not as a
thank-you gesture write someone a
recommendation or endorse them and I'm
sure that in return they will do the
same for you and social media engagement
is all about - way to stream interaction
so why not start one you know whether it
be send an email or post this that post
an update engaging a company profile
page those are some of the ways
additionally um your employer's also
especially in Silicon Valley also look
very closely at your online web presence
phrase um to have a better understanding
for example last year firm called Union
Square Ventures they used they
completely forgot the the whole
traditional resume submission process
and opted for links set of links
anything from blogs to Twitter accounts
and earlier this year a firm called
entrances which is a US tech company for
its chief mark chief social media
strategy strategist position there are
two requirements number one is to submit
your resume through these twice amazed
which are 140 Ward 140 letter resumes
and number two you must have at least a
thousand followers so hopefully I've
demonstrated to you how your online
identity can
packed with your job search and before I
have it off over to Santiago I would
like to leave to caution you that social
media is simply a tool and not him and
not a solution in and of itself and
nothing beats meeting people
face-to-face shaking your hand and
telling them I really want to work for
you now in the interest of all speaking
sure you're aware of these critical
factors of how not to be judged that
quickly we decided you have to take a
little bit extra time and given that
we're only gonna open up the floor for
one question so who's the lucky one go
ahead
I think that two things will be you pay
attention to the first things is what
kind of company like international you
or try to W you want to apply for some
like a job in investing banking even in
China organization contain almost the
same and the several things is even you
can use the same way you pay attention
sometimes the HR people maybe ask the
more information or coming to shoot
their criterias so in summary make sure
that you understand that you have 30
seconds figure out how to keep things
clear and pointing the right directions
make sure that you're tuning to the
right context you speak the right
language you present the right
information and you manage yourself
digitally thank you